the question as to whether or not we are
hard-wired for religion and spirituality
I think is is a very important one when
we look at how the brain works
it looks like the brain is able to very
easily engage in religious and spiritual
practices ideas and experiences all the
brain scan studies that we've done show
that there are multiple parts of the
brain that seem to get involved so it
really does look like the brain is so
easily capable of having these
experiences now exactly how that ability
got into the brain is of course a much
more complex and both philosophical and
scientific question the scientists would
say well maybe it was through millions
of years of evolution that because being
religious or spiritual was an adaptive
process it got incorporated into the
biological mechanisms of the brain and
there's certainly a lot of reasons to
support that and of course if you're a
religious individual it also makes sense
that if there's a god up there and we're
down here that we would have a brain
that's capable of communicating to God
praying to God doing the things that God
needs us to do otherwise there would be
this kind of fundamentally silly
disconnect we wouldn't we wouldn't be
able to have any kind of interaction
with God so it does look like the brain
no matter how it got there does have
this profound ability to engage in
religious and spiritual experiences and
and that's part of why we've seen
religion and spirituality be a part of
human history since the very dawn of
civilization one of the things that we
find to be such an important element of
many of the rituals and practices that
people do as part of their religious
traditions is the repetition of it the
more that you come back to a particular
idea the more you focus on it the more
you say a phrase or a prayer those are
the ideas and beliefs that become
written into the neural connections of
the brain there's a cute saying the
neurons that fire together wire together
the idea is is that when you are doing a
particular practice whatever it is
religious or otherwise the more you do
it the more you are writing that
information into the neural connections
of the brain the neurons that support
that idea or support that practice fire
together they strengthen their
connections and it makes it easier for
you to come back to that particular
practice
and it also strengthens the beliefs that
are around that particular practice now
that's also why we think that a practice
like meditation even taken into a more
secular kind of context can be a very
powerful tool for helping to improve the
way a person's brain works the analogy
here I think is if you were to wanting
to become a better tennis player for
example well you could do one of two
things one is you've got to play tennis
you got to keep practicing the tennis
itself the other is that you could go to
the weight room and lift weights or you
could run which is more general
strengthening and conditioning now if
you wanted to become a good basketball
player you wouldn't play tennis you'd
shoot baskets but the weight training
and the aerobic training can be good for
both so meditation may fall into that
area where you know maybe you want to be
really good at doing crossword puzzles
you want to do a lot of crossword
puzzles but if you get really good at
crossword puzzles it doesn't make you a
good chess player but if you do
meditation practices it might make you
better either in doing crossword puzzles
or being a good chess player or maybe
even being a better athlete so it has
something to do I think with how we can
more generally improve the function of
the brain that these kinds of practices
actually can help with so well if you're
at your desk and you do feel like you
really need you know the world is just
flying around you and you need to take a
moment you can literally just sit there
at your desk put everything down you can
close your eyes and for hopefully you
can close your door or block out your
ears or something like that and simply
sit there for about a minute or so and
just concentrate on your breath just
feel your breathing in take a deep
breath in hold it for a moment let the
breath go out and as you do that just
concentrate on that breath coming in and
the breath coming out if you want to you
can actually focus a little bit on some
of the areas of your body especially if
you have some discomfort or stress
you're feeling maybe a headache or
something like that you can concentrate
on that a little bit let yourself feel
it and then each time you feel it then
just go back to the breath breathing in
and breathing out and if you do that for
60 seconds maybe 2 minutes
then you can open your eyes back up and
return back to your work but you will
feel that little bit of rejuvenation
you'll feel a little bit better focus
and you'll be able to go back to
concentrating a little bit better on
whatever the next task is at hand